with Sentinel death's Rising Recovery
Specialists are urging more people to
carry things like Narcan and naloxone
joining us to discuss overdoses Dr
Andrea Peterson with empowered at
Roseman University College of Medicine
one of the sponsors for our special
tomorrow night called what every family
needs to know about fentanyl Dr Peterson
also a pharmacist thank you so much for
being here thanks for having me here to
talk about this really important topic
it really is and we know that naloxone
and Narcan they reverse an overdose from
opioids be it heroin Fentanyl and
prescription opioid medications so what
actually happens to the body when one or
both of these is used correct so you hit
exactly it's an opioid reversal agent so
this is something that's not going to
work for any other type of an overdose
and it really just kicks that opioid off
of the receptor in the body that's
giving in its effect it's available
intranasally and intramuscularly some
people are aware right now that it's
going over the counter for the
intranasal formulation we're really not
quite sure what the cost implications of
that will be okay and where do you think
these two items should be read readily
available everywhere easy answer
everywhere if you're at a school concert
sporting venue anywhere that we have and
lots of people and really in our homes
as well a big risk with fentanyl being
on our streets right now is that any
substance that's obtained illicitly can
be laced with this so it's really
important that we have it in our
families and we have available for
widespread use you know during our
special on Saturday night we talked to
doctors we talk to teenagers they're
concerned we talk to everybody involved
with this and you talk about anything
involved with an illicit substance does
your average family have to be concerned
about something like this absolutely
especially where we have our kids at
school and we're not sure if somebody is
bringing something from another home
yeah I think it's really important to
hit on three different topics and that
really is avoidance again any substance
can be laced with fentanyl prevention so
making sure that we have access to
Narcan in our homes and everywhere that
we're going again like you've mentioned
and then also I just want to briefly hit
on the fact that if somebody suspects
that they have an opioid use disorder or
a loved one there's hope there's hope
there's resources available
we thank you so much for your time
doctor greatly appreciate it and thank
you also for being a huge sponsor of our
special that airs this Saturday evening
we understand too there's a resource for
people if they have questions the Envy
opioidresponse.org will have treatment
options and then it will also have a
locator to be able to find Narcan that's
near you it'll be at pharmacies and then
there's also distribution sites where
you can obtain it free okay and you can
find that information as well on eight
news now thank you again Roseman
University a sponsor of our special
tomorrow night what every family needs
to know about Sentinel tomorrow night at
8 pm followed by a q a live on Facebook
right after at 9pm